speaks of a favor and go just go click
on something else really you don't want
to stay here you won't survive it I'm
barely survived it this movie is
horrendous it's just golly the unnatural
if a piece of shit took a piece of shit
that piece of shit took a piece I said
it I'm taste I checked on her
face-to-face I shut that piece of shit
made a movie and I'm moving took a piece
of shit and I gotta check your wife's a
Felix the Cat I know what you're
thinking what that black-and-white
cartoon from God knows when how could a
film based on that thing be as horrible
as I'm making it out to be how could
some innocent animation from the 20s
possibly affect someone in the most
horrendous ways you can imagine you've
been warned ok so we start off this
movie with you sure you don't want to
turn back there's still time
I'm sure angry Joe has a good video ok
so we start off this film about the
classic 2d animated character with of
course some classic 2d animate what the
fuck - puss oh hi everybody
glad you could make it and hundreds of
screaming kids go running out of the
theater you see I just got back from the
land of Orianna Wow you almost had
actual lip movement there that time keep
it up and your mouth might actually
closed a few times when you say a
sentence come to think of it I don't
even know if I could get back there
myself and in case you're wondering no
there's no other 3d animation in the
entire picture so really this is
completely pointless
it's like watching that annoying Mario
head at the opening of Mario 64 yeah it
looked nice then but it's awkward and
disturbing now which one of our voice is
more than I
so okay so after we're done with cat
head room we finally get our type Felix
the Cat yay we then see the land of
Orianna where princess Orianna
bit of an ego trip there is busy running
her country when she suddenly
interrupted I hope I'm not disturbing I
always have time for you this increase
in credits you've created it's just
unheard of oh god this movie's gonna
hurt okay so you might notice well to be
perfectly honest all the problems with
the movie in the first two minutes yeah
actually everything wrong with this film
you can sum up in literally the first
two minutes firstly the animation is
obnoxious
it needs rhythm second it has the same
problem as the magic voyage it's just
constant noise all throughout the film
it never takes a break the dude comes
down he's gotten through the impasse
with a hot mommy almost yeah yes Yugi
but surprisingly this film is even worse
why because the sound mixing is so bad
that half the time you can't even make
out what they're saying
give the magic voyage some credit I at
least heard every piece of shit dialogue
that was written third the lip movements
almost never match what the characters
are saying look at this scene the guy
never closes his mouth
I will delay them for as long as I can i
moan they won't harm me go see from
consonants but hey seeing how we can't
hear what the characters are saying at
the time anyway I guess it doesn't
matter it's two minutes two minutes and
already I want to stab a puppy and eat
people pray for the apocalypse people we
have 80 more minutes of this shit okay
so what I could gather over the
underwater audio is that the princess is
uncle names ill that's the name no one
which awful blah where I come from is in
the process of taking over her Kingdom
may I remind you princess Orianna
that since you disbanded the army there
is now no defense against such a
possibility Thank You grumper I don't
need to be reminded ah clearly you do
because that was a pretty jackass move
you got rid of your entire army what are
that the princess why did you dispose of
army yeah well in the history books has
anybody ever taken the government down
you're joking right
even if someone tried to break in I
would just hold my dress on both sides
and think happy thoughts
doesn't that sound the most logical this
conversation makes me feel drunk so they
tried to get her out through a hidden
tunnel but the doctor who robots are
close in on their tails
you see so they are with the evil boxes
oh don't you talk about my boxes I like
boxes and come across a room where a
machine that can jump dimensions is kept
I do hope the demesne Porter still works
it's so oh wait a minute so old we have
an ungodly powerful dimensional
transporter and you never use that this
pinball
I've been using it to make hot chocolate
but the machines grab her before she can
get it to work
um thank God that 1980s music video
tears suddenly turned gold and activated
the machine it happens
good what are we God her tears are
incredible I mean if that's just what
they can do imagine what her snot could
be capable of
so the tear goes to a totally different
dimension on its own it's alive yeah and
it looks for a dimension not nearly a
stranger surreal as the ones are
currently it doesn't come to our world
well I'm gonna say no on that because
even though it looks like our world
there's cars in it like our world
there's even humans in it like our world
there's a talking cat who walks around
with everyday people and carries a
magical bag that he can somehow morph
into anything so clearly it's not our
everyday normal world why does this get
me so angry
well because it raises the question why
the fuck do we have a different
dimension in this movie why couldn't
Felix just be in Orianna the strange
world
he's already strange he's a talking cat
it's not like the real world meets
something other than whimsical it's real
- shit meeting we're - shut so this plot
point has no purpose it's just wasting
time something you'll find this movie is
very very good at Oh
so as you can hear
Felix's dialogue is about as complex as
an itchy and scratchy cartoon oh hell
even they have more respectable dialogue
than this crap so what Felix is chasing
the magical flying golden tier someone
had to write that - scientists are
watching him because apparently they
want control of his magic bag yes uncle
this must be something really big if
he's got his bag he is yes in the bag I
always wanted that bag perhaps this is
an ideal opportunity for me to acquire
it so this may sound weird but I think
Felix the cat has way too much story
there's like a million things going on
at once in this movie you're not
directing inception it's Felix the
fucking cat does this really warrant a
song it's just some foxes looking at a
bag why does this lend itself to a
musical accompany just tap pots down lay
they must be learning from the Randy
Newman school of pointless songwriting
fuck they like looking at bay and then
they walk away through their tails are
gonna weigh you buddy Randy now he
follows the tear down a hole where he
sees the remains of an old mine I think
I'm starting to fall for you ha ha boy
could you use a Big Mac huh boy Felix is
kind of sick isn't he
does he always laugh at the dead when he
comes across them ha ha ha ha you stupid
skull ha ha ha ha all right time to get
some reading done people who died at the
hands of Joseph Stalin so he finds
himself in the dimensional jumper upper
rank gets sent to Orianna
but he's trapped in a room and uses his
magic bag to drill his way out
Oh
okay this is making the yellow submarine
look sober it's just pointless nonsense
on top of pointless nonsense
in fact what was that line used to
describe IO cane powder in the Princess
Bride
it is odorless tasteless and is among
the more deadly poisonous known to man
yeah that's this movie that's this
fucking movie
by the way I should point out that
Felix's magic bag really has no logical
reasoning to it he just sort of looks at
it lasers come out his eyes and suddenly
it transforms into whatever he wants
there's no limitation or understanding
of it at all we don't even know where it
came from or how he got it he just
starts off with it and hey it's a magic
bag don't question it you know maybe
that would work better in the 1920s when
animation was new and it horrified
people oh my god I'll catch doing things
with a bag hi Georgia but when this came
out it makes about as much sense as it
does now hey stranger I speak for the
trees why don't you just follow me by
yourself you can get in a lot of trouble
out here
look out that's painted into the
background so obviously it's not gonna
move but the old man traps him in a
cherie sperm and hands him over to a
circus entertainer who wants to exploit
his magic bag meanwhile dr. wily and dr.
honeydew try following Felix to see if
they can capture his bag as well
Felix is definitely over his head this
time a farmer's less than you would
expect
well that's going on the Entertainer
tries to force Felix to show how to use
his magic bag what is your name all
right let's try again what is your name
look is he doing yeah yeah that's real
good
listen pussycat you want to eat then you
work my name is Felix stop that you're
getting way too much enjoyment out of
whatever you're doing
what does even tell the person who is
animating that alright I want you to
make it look like he's dry humping a
trash can no questions dammit no
questions I have a very specific vision
so the show slash circus slash thing
that the entertainer runs finally begins
and you're not gonna believe it it's
really loud obnoxious and annoying
-
okay I have no idea why they just showed
her face right there but let me tell you
it sums up the movie that's the face I'm
gonna make throughout the entire flick
ah this whole sequence is like a bad
fever dream after watching Pink Floyd's
the wall right
Felix performs and it turns out he's a
big hit with his magic bag why he
doesn't just turn it into a
semi-automatic and blow the shit out of
everybody I don't know but he does make
all the fragglerock Kremlin's happy you
did good
you're a born performer we don't see the
princess is forced to perform while
dancing inside a bubble fortune bubbles
why is it princesses can never seem to
get out of bubbles like princess Daphne
don't all they have to do is pop it I
mean this is a rocket science in fact
this whole movie seems like a lost Don
Bluth game dragons suck I can't keep my
sanity guess what that constant pounding
sound coming from the robot is not
vitally important to hear but maybe the
inner thoughts of one of our main
characters holds a little bit more
weight but not likely I'm not gonna hurt
you
so keep you friends these two my issue
for some reason dress up like lizards
and for some reason can chew through
metal this it's not evil worth
questioning as they let him out and lead
him up to the princess's cell this may
sound crazy but I'm not from around here
I followed a tear with an image your
image inside it and Here I am because of
you the tear the demands quarter the
other dimension did get through yeah
because apparently tears and really bad
animated movies have the power to start
up dimensional transporters and talk
with dolphins with the help of magical
moonbeams how come tears are like
mythical stargates in these films when
my father was still alive there was a
small army more for ceremonial occasions
than anything else but there was one
person who didn't like the way things
were my uncle it works it will
revolutionize labor life
was it supposed to do that he was
horribly disfigured but he's wait it's
not horribly disfigured he looks fine
but he get a pimple in that fiery is too
embarrassed to show it off
my father had entrusted me with the
royal secrets and the location of the
book of ultimate power it's this book
that the Duke so desperately wants the
book of ultimate power yeah why don't
you just call it a more obvious name
like the goody good good that people
really want Avanti my poor country
I fear time is running out for it we
will get out of here I promise you yeah
so again even though the king and queen
are totally dead she still technically
calls herself princess how does that
work if you're the war of a nation
you're a fucking Queen you know we never
did hear her first name maybe she
legally changed it to princess just so
she can keep the title given the fact
that she threw her armies out even
though there's a crazy-ass uncle who
wanted her dead it wouldn't surprise me
so while they're trying to figure a way
out the two doctors are trying to figure
a way in excuse me miss how much is it
to enter this establishment got credits
for a dog school for children okay I'll
take it enjoy the show he paid with
branches movie I really tried to
understand you but you shut down that Oh
this whole movie is like a feeding on
your child's brains and if I was
diagnosed with a terminal illness and
the only cure for it was watching this
film
another terminal illness satellite to
die faster alright ladies and germs step
right up and see the greatest and the
latest right in our ring but Felix has a
brilliant plan I guess which is blowing
a bunch of bubbles out of his saxophone
and somehow they float away on that like
you you're escaping you let them
outsmart you
curses I knew someday bubbles would be
my undoing so they get away along with
stinky Pete who I guess is a good guy
now but the skittles electric parade is
on the go and they have to get a move on
so they come across the professor's who
are trying to steal the bag but Felix
deals it right back I don't suppose you
have anything that belongs to me I was
bringing it to you Wow
so they were really essential to the
story give me the bag oh okay so they
come across our hair forest dime not
questioning it why should you but even
more strange creatures come to do
strange things
okay yes I think so oh that one pussy
scream really seemed to take a lot out
of me headhunter it's like if dr. Seuss
really hated shield and wanted to give
parents a way of punishing them without
necessarily beating them and yet the
psychological scars would still be the
same listen to that cheap eighties music
does this match at all
what felix has another brilliant idea
hats just don't get you obey I don't
dare you the IQ fence this movie is
where somebody's drug money went
they had hide it somewhere so how about
a film that obviously had no effort put
into it whatsoever
and a top of that nobody would ever see
its genius
PR diabolical genius oh thank god we're
almost at the end okay so the uncle
comes across our heroes and forces them
to show where the book of power is
what is this some kind of joke
I've been suffering and working all
these years for this crap
hey at least those years were in
flashback we had to sit through a whole
hour and a half for this weak-ass twist
and speaking of weak-ass twist just as
the uncle threatens them with a giant
killer robot
Felix literally throws the book at him
and that actually defeats it yes nothing
likes showing truth love and wisdom than
by tricking your enemy with all your
hatred through the dumbest and most
barbaric of idiotic methods true we've
learned a lot from this movie so Felix
tries to go back to his dimension but it
turns out none of the goal the
professor's brought is able to pass
through and I have a feeling your gold
will pass through the demons corner but
princess I don't have any gold you're
wrong feelings you do you have a heart a
soul
oh fuck you you decapitated Macy's Day
balloon you are set on a deck miss mommy
yes moving I mean my god
it is horrendously bad beyond annoying
every second is like a kid to my
ballsack the story the characters
everything about it is like a little kid
jumping on her bed screaming it's just
loud grating and makes no sense
it's one of the worst people one of the
worst I've ever had to sit through it is
a piece oh yeah there are no words to
describe it that there's only one single
solitary image thank you I'm the
Nostalgia Critic run my children run
your breathe it's horrible cauldron of
you